he's none other than ion eagle back here
in the show how are you I'm yeah very
little-known band and he is touchups
Minh Arkell one-hit wonder wonder where
they are now yes they're there I think
what they do is they touch they they are
touring with a a heap of bonner
is what they did keep a Bonner which is
what I got man hold on a second you're
not on Instagram are you I am oh come on
I have multiple multiple burner accounts
absolutely you've gained weight in Italy
I know yeah you see doing a show like
this I share too much I just share a
little too much oh my gosh how great is
this matchup tonight I mean you got
yourself a big fat double-dip this is
huge yeah starting with that yes let's
start with the late game first and it's
Kentucky full-bore is everybody healthy
tell me about this this story playing
out with the Wildcats
iein yeah my sense it's just a gut
feeling I think PJ Washington will play
I don't necessarily think he'll start I
don't think he'll play 2025 minutes but
I think he'll make an appearance from
what I saw yesterday he moved around
fairly well he wasn't exploding off that
left foot
he wasn't pushing it by any stretch but
he participated just enough to convince
me just my viewpoint no inside
information that he's going to suit up
and and give it a whirl but how they use
him might be dictated on the game and
how the game goes Kentucky they're going
against tough Houston team
this team is relevant again Kelvin
Samson has gotten to a point where they
have to be respected because of the
defense that they play they are card
oriented but they're gonna make it pay
and they're physical enough on the
perimeter and inside that they're a
tough team to score against did this to
me is is a pick'em game this is a battle
with PJ Washington or without him and
then the opening game North Carolina and
Auburn as you are calling it on TBS back
in the studio you have the hearts and
minds of both Barkley and Kenny Smith
this is a big one just in in the hole
Warner media world to ion rich do you
work in television yes I do except this
this seems as if you have a good feel
for what could be a sidebar story to our
broadcast how Kenny and Charles are
involved still remains to be seen but
there there's probably going to be some
kind of connection over the course of
the broadcast where Kenny and Charles
will be included in the fun the madness
and the mayhem this is a track meet
these two teams love to go up and down
the floor they play with pace they
intimidate you with that pace yet
neither will be intimidated by the idea
of running in transition that's what
North Carolina does
that's what Auburn does against the 14
other teams that had qualified for the
sweet 16 now obviously we've whittled it
down I think they would have had an
advantage in some form against every
other team but not necessarily against
each other so you start digging a little
deeper North Carolina tremendous
rebounding team number one in college
basketball and rebounding margin Auburn
has a negative rebounding margin and
then assists North Carolina shares the
ball as well as anybody number two in
the country questions about this year
little talented freshman it was dealing
with the flu but my understanding
earlier today is he's going to give it a
go that he's feeling better he's a young
guy he's bounced back physically and
they think he can give them some minutes
tonight okay and do you do the same
thing with coupes as you do with with
football where you meet with coaches as
in as brought with a broadcasting
meeting and stuff like that to do the
same thing or no no yeah we do we get
them we get them off to the side during
their their set ninety minutes of
practice so usually last 1012 minutes we
we get a little meet-and-greet we get
some nuggets and tidbits met with all
for them yesterday and feeling pretty
good about the storylines going into
this one these are two games that could
easily live up to what we see on paper
coach Cal that must be a fun 10-minute
12-minute session what I've learned with
Coach Cal remember I know him forever he
was the head coach of the nets in 1996 I
was in my third year at that point
broadcasting the Nets so there's a lot
of history there he is
he's like a prizefighter he can deflect
he can knock away he can absorb and yet
still not necessarily answer anything
you ask yes so at depth and he also
understands timing like if we have 10
minutes with him he could filibuster for
nine minutes and 21 seconds then you're
like oh ok well say so by now it's it's
just it's a gift I once interviewed him
on this show while he was on an
elliptical that happened that actually
happened he was doing court and the show
they're saying he's a multitasker rich
that's what the hey look you don't just
be you don't just get to that position
in that were in that without being a
multitasker and it's amazing that you
you you were calling games when he was
the coach of the nets my gosh that's a
yeah that's a bull yeah so does he ask
you how the nuts are doing at all or no
never I would say there was there was
about a 10-year stretch that every time
he saw me and I'm not exaggerating this
in any way shape or form every single
time he saw me he would turn around and
say they smoking
I'm like yeah no I know I heard about
that and then finally after he won the
national championship I feel like it
dissipated and he doesn't just assign
that experience in his life for the
moment that he sees me one of the times
over the course of the 10 years I
finally said to my John you know I
played no role in that they did not ask
my opinion I don't know if you think
somehow I was tied in I was just calling
the games but it did stick with him for
a long time because he hasn't failed at
anything and that would be the one thing
that didn't quite live up to what he
thought it could be being an NBA head
coach I Neagle here on the Rich Eisen
show let's talk about those Brooklyn
Nets looks like they're going to the
playoffs I know that there's a there's a
lot more to be played and obviously it's
very tight it's gonna come down to the
wire but sitting there at 500 and
DeAngelo Russell he has been revelatory
what what happened to the Brooklyn Nets
this season all right yeah I think a few
things one everything they said they
were gonna do they've done developing
players developing a culture creating a
environment where coaches and players
work together and it's all about
improvement and getting the most out of
what you bring they said all those
things and they've done all those things
that's three years worth of living up to
what you said this could be and there
are a lot of GM's that say things and a
lot of coaches that say things it
doesn't mean that they actually do them
Sean marks and Kenny ikenson they've
they've done what they've said players
have gotten better D'Angelo Russell has
gotten better Joe Harris has gotten
better
Kerris levert and Spencer didn't would
he have gotten better Jared Allen you
can go on and on and ultimately I think
that appeals to players and they're
trying to create not just an optic but a
reality that agents and players are now
considering the nets and that's hard to
do and they've done that in a very short
period of time and it's actually
translated to wins I think that's been
the best part is that there's there are
results that they can lean on and say
look this was the cause and effect how
it all plays out you're right it's very
tight right now it's gotten a little
tighter than they anticipated and it may
come down to the final game wouldn't
shock me if they play Miami in the final
game of the season and a playoff spot is
on the line for both of them
there were Dwayne Wade's career
potentially being over correcting the
balance as well it's an amazing two that
the Nets went through that period that
you mentioned the three-year period
where it was so brutal it was so
difficult and I'm sure it was difficult
for the fans and yet ownership never
threatened the fans calling them drunks
or kicking them out or telling them to
watch enjoy watch him on TV I mean
that's very strange isn't it the
ownership wouldn't do that in New York
City yeah I know it's funny I saw
Mikhail Prokhorov who's a large man in
this interesting man and maybe the
world's most interesting man a Russian
billionaire and he was at a game yeah
let's say it was about six weeks ago
when the nets were no longer just a nice
story they proved that they actually
were a factor that they were relevant
again and I'm walking out of the arena
and he's standing there and I turned to
him and I said hey congratulations on
everything that's going on and his first
reaction to me was no congratulations to
you that you now get to broadcast a fun
team that's the thought process to me
that that says it all ownership really
wanted to do this for Brooklyn and make
Brooklyn a destination again and that's
been a big part of their focus from day
one and to see it actually unfold has
has really been exciting from from my
perspective who's now been doing this
job for literally 25 years so do they
have a chance at the big free agents
this summer I mean everybody's focusing
on the Lakers out here and obviously
yeah the Knicks having that putting all
their eggs in that porzingis trade
basket and
Clippers out here as well I mean what's
the net situation where you think they
can make a run with Brooklyn here yeah I
think they're gonna be in the
conversation and to me that was the
first step to get into the batter's box
they were not even being mentioned or
pondered with big time agents and big
name for reagents and now all of a
sudden they'll get meetings and they
will be noticed and they're popping up
in some of the speculation that that was
that was a big part of the process to to
just be considered now how that plays
out I have no idea you know everyone's
got their own agenda and there might be
things that have already been determined
for all we know and that's been a lot of
the conjecture in the New York area but
until you put pen to paper as we've
learned in sports I don't believe it I'm
gonna wait and reserve judgment until
the Nets actually get a chance to make
their pitch okay I am before we let you
go what's going to be that that tug on
the air for for me and our show that we
always do during the broadcast yeah I
know what will be that Carol Burnett tug
on the air moment a shout-out during
some sort of promotional read your
undies do you have is it just TBS yeah
that's so it's just TBS inventory yes
okay
TBS tonight so it's a little different
we're pushing more ellen barkin vehicles
than ever before I believe okay
could it be part of the promo I think
that's the first time I've ever said in
my life
Ellen Barkin vehicles would be a great
fantasy match up with a touch of sparkle
that would be that'd be quite the
fantasy magic honor the American Dad I
mean what do we got I mean what are you
gonna what do you what are you blast
ogia the last og a great well that's the
Tracy Morgan show that would be a great
there'd be a great yeah okay so what can
we do you tell me I'm
I don't know I'm hoping probably
personally honest with you I'm waiting
for the Rich Eisen show is coming to be
our live pearl mob and you know I mean I
don't want to sleep on that is that in
the inventory anyway tonight I I did not
see that all right
dealer's choice dealer's choice
I'm whatever you got all right just have
to trust me okay I will just and I'll
just I'll know is what I mean I'll know
I mean it'll just stand right up hey
enjoy Kansas City and I look forward to
hearing the call tonight of two
fantastic games from the Sprint Center
appreciate it yeah looking forward to it
rich
Ciao Bella designing the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience